hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is alex mollering and i'm going
to be your instructor this evening and i
have a fun one planned for you uh if
anyone here is a fan of star wars the
force is going to be with us
tonight we're going to be talking about
forcing moves a really important concept
in chess that if you're not super
familiar with
or only
vaguely familiar with this can actually
elevate your chest to another level
um i'm actually taking a lot of this
information at least the basics of
forcing moves from some articles by gm
brian smith uh i found them on chess.com
if you just go to chess.com and look up
like brian smith or forcing moves he has
a two-part article titled forcing moves
i highly recommend it and i'm going to
be using some of that for this lecture
but to start out um i want to take a
look at this example so
this is a composition i found on
chess.com as well
by g shapiro and it's talking about
forcing moves so
when we think about a forcing move in
chess what do we mean a forcing move is
essentially just any move you play
that forces your opponent to respond in
a very specific way
the most common examples are checks and
captures so anytime you check
you're forcing your opponent to
you know get out of check somehow
whether they're moving their king or
blocking the check or taking the
attacking piece
off the board
uh a capture is another example um you
might not think of just like trading
pawns in the beginning of a game like a
forcing move but often if your opponent
doesn't recapture
then they're just down a pawn and you're
going to have an advantage for very
little reason
so that's what we mean by a forcing move
usually it's going to be a checker
capture and it essentially forces your
opponent to respond in a specific way
there are some big benefits when we
think about forcing moves in chess so
taking this example
there's a few moves that come to mind
when we think of forcing moves so
you might think of maybe a crazy
sacrifice like queen takes on d2 r sorry
e2 or rook takes on e2 both of these
would be checks
maybe a move like bishop to d2 check or
bishop takes knight check
um
those are probably the most forcing
moves we have in this position
and the reason we're going to start with
those is
well there are several reasons is one
those are going to be the easiest to
calculate because our opponent's
response is so limited
if i'm looking at this position and i'm
thinking maybe a strong idea would be to
notice that i'm castled kingside my
opponent hasn't committed to castling
yet so maybe i'm going to fight on the
king side
maybe push up this
attack of the night um disincentivized
castling
uh because my bishop is stopping them
from castling queenside this is a very
positional idea
and it's something maybe worth
considering at some point
but if we notice after we play the move
h5 our opponent has so many options the
trying to understand what they might do
is actually very unrealistic
they can push this pawn up two spaces
they can castle their king
they can move their knight somewhere
they can move their queen to make
threats they can develop their piece all
of these moves we have to be aware as
possibilities
and to start out that's hard to
calculate we might have to do that
but if we can start with the forcing
moves it's going to be much quicker so
let's look at some of the examples i
talked about
queen takes e2 or rook takes e2 are both
very forcing
the slight problem
right black has to respond if you move
the king
well if the queen takes you can't
if the rook takes you can but you
probably shouldn't because the obvious
response will be
knight recaptures
um
if knight wasn't there this would be a
checkmate threat
but that can help us start to see okay
well obviously i can't just give this up
because they take back and i don't
really have anything to follow up but
now i'm thinking okay wait a minute this
knight is tying everything together
so i have a forcing move where i can
take a piece
and call check
so that's gonna be how we start
um and so let's calculate this before we
even play it bishop takes knight
if they recapture
then it's actually just checkmate right
we already saw
that this is a checkmate threat
and without the night there to take the
king will be lost
so they cannot recapture our bishop
so what other options do they have right
we need to think all of this through
well if our bishop here is here and they
don't recapture then they have to move
their king
nothing can come in and block
so the only moves they have
uh they certainly can't move the king to
where the bishop is still attacking so
this is out they could move to f1
they could move to d2 and they could
move to d1
so these are the three moves we need to
consider
again we don't have to think about the h
pawn recapturing because once we find
in our calculation that there's either a
forced checkmate threat or
we're just up a very decisive advantage
you can stop calculating and just
continue from there
so considering these three options
knowing that the point of taking the
knight and removing it is so that we can
remove the defender of this pawn on e2
once the king has moved to either of
these squares
sorry
any of these three squares
our queen can take and this will be
check
if the king has gone to f1 right we have
to think of all these branching paths
the king has gone to f1
then the next move is forced the king
will have to move to g1
and from there we probably can find a
checkmate quite easily
i think the easiest way to do it um
would be something like bishop to well
no bishop to e3 the queen is covering
oh i forgot our bishop is on g3 because
it took the knight so the bishop is
actually covering the square and we can
just bring the bishop in so let's just
take a look at that very quickly
again if they take here this is
checkmate we already looked at this
so king to f2 there's our king to f1
queen takes check
the king is forced to g1
and now with our bishop covering these
squares
we can simply play queen to f2
checkmate
um i actually think this is also
checkmate so pick your boys in there
but again we've gone through a variation
so we would have in in a real game right
we were sitting over the board we would
do this in our heads
we figured out okay we've eliminated
this as an option they can't take our
night because we're winning the game
they can't move to f1 because we're
winning the game so now they only have
two options left
to go to d2
or uh or d1
on either of those squares we're still
probably going to take this pawn right
it's another forcing move and regardless
of where they go they're actually forced
into one single square for both so again
we're reducing the amount of things
we're calculating here
to simplify this demonstration i will
just show what this looks like
oh sorry they can't take
king here and if they go to d2 it's the
same
we take and they're forced to c1 and
from here there's lots of ways to
continue but noticing that our queen has
fully trapped this king the best move
here is going to be bishop to f4 again
thinking forcing moves
the king has no more spaces to go no
escape
so the knight can block or the queen
will have to block and be lost
um
however if knight comes to d2 we
actually have a really beautiful
response
as white or sorry as black so in this
position black to move and find the best
move see if you can figure it out
do you have any suggestions
i am not a gm no i'm about 1500 15
40.
uh something like that
uh yeah queenie won with the idea that
after the rook takes
uh our work will recapture so yeah sorry
sagebrush c black to move queen to e1
check rook takes and this is a checkmate
uh just for fun
if they had blocked with the queen their
best move is actually to play queen to
e3
because if they play queen to d2 we can
take the queen
but we can actually do the even dirtier
queen to e1 anyway
because their queen is pinned
um but regardless if you're a beginning
player you don't need to you know find
the perfect move every time it's good if
you can um but winning a queen
should be good enough here and you can
stop the calculations at this point
returning to our original position
we can see some immediate benefits to
forcing moves
one
oh sorry if the description is a little
off but yeah
one the forcing move helps us to limit
our opponent's options when we're
calculating so instead of playing a
strategic move like h5 we can actually
think um
okay in this case they have hundreds of
options
whereas after bishop takes they are
limited to literally one two three
four only four moves and of those we can
continue to eliminate right if they re
recapture its checkmate so that's one
move down
king to f1
is checkmate in two
we can take that one down right and we
can keep eliminating moves
now if you find that no forcing moves in
a position win
then you start to consider other options
but imagine if we had started this
position by calculating the move h5
and thinking about everything white
could do if this would be a good
long-term advantage
maybe this would have been a good
long-term advantage
but we would have had to spend so much
time figuring out whether this move was
worth it that we would have just missed
what was right under our eyes
um
so
elimination limitation i'm not sure
exactly what you're talking about um
sumblative what i would guess is
when we eliminate an option when i was
saying like we can eliminate a variation
in my mind i'm thinking of something
like this
i'm imagining i take on g3 and if h
takes back
then i know that this is checkmate
so in my calculation
i don't have to think once i've reached
a checkmate or a crushing advantage in
the variation i don't have to think
about that anymore so i can cross off
that as a variation
similarly how we noticed where after the
king goes to
d2 or d1 and we call check
both of these variations transpose so
they come back together
on uh where the king goes to c1 so we
don't have to think about both of those
we can just combine them into one
so that's kind of what i mean there
so hopefully you're clear on that but
it's a really really powerful idea um
the rest of this lesson is going to be a
little different than some of my
previous ones
basically for the rest of the lesson
we're going to be looking at puzzles
that i've pulled off of lee chess so
this is just a random assortment of
different kinds of puzzles some easier
some harder but all of them involve this
idea of forcing moves so whenever we
start looking we want to calculate the
forcing moves
all right in this position it is black
to move
[Music]
so let's start by thinking about our
forcing moves here so i don't have any
suggestions for black
what do you want
yeah um what's the idea
after working one
um
yeah so
this is essentially a back rank um their
king can't escape the only move is to
block
and it doesn't matter which work we take
with either way it's checkmate
um
and again we can think this through like
how quick was that right we immediately
got to a checkmate now again these are
designed in a certain way so this won't
always be the case in your games but
there's a value here um we could also
have thought maybe what if rook takes
work first and we can see that king
takes rook and we can maybe call some
checks but we don't really have much of
a follow-up and we're not going to be
able to beat their queen and rook and we
can eliminate that as
an idea
all right next position here white to
move
so we have several forcing moves in this
position
taking a look at them see if you can
find one that might work for us
yeah sambalatib uh you got the right
idea bishop takes f7 but again we want
to think of more the the broader scheme
here wizard takes f7 is force is a
forcing move because
the king is forced into two options it
can either take or can run away
um if they run away
then we just went upon and we took away
their casting rights so we can eliminate
that variation we don't have to
calculate farther because that's going
to be good enough for us
so the other option is obviously they
take the most likely option
but if they do that i think you see the
follow-up
after king takes like you said there is
a discovery
knight to g5 check
and we discover an attack on the bishop
with our queen uh wherever the king
moves we will take the bishop so if
something like king to g8
queen takes bishop
and
we traded bishops we sacrificed ours and
got blacks but we also won this pawn and
have put black in a really uncomfortable
position where they can't castle
um and again we found that by seeing oh
well maybe there's this again we've
talked about the weak square here on f2
and f7 where especially the king hasn't
castled the king is the only thing
defending that so being able to leverage
that to our advantage here helps us
find the right idea
i do not know the pebbis gambit so i
have no comments on it
all right black to move
see if we can find the winning idea here
um
i don't know exactly what if for dowsie
is a person or like a organization or
something but all of these puzzles were
literally just pulled from late chess i
went to the
leaguechess.org and they're just puzzles
and just did different types of tactics
some more checkmates some more
sacrifices
and i found
something you'll notice in puzzles is a
lot of them are forcing moves um because
that involves the most calculation now
not all of them are but a lot do um
so
okay so knight to f3 this is check
and
let's look at where our king can go
so
our knight here is covering these two
squares the bishop is covering these two
so after check
the king only has one square
okay so what do we do after king to d1
i'm trying to um which
square is the best to move it to
um
i think
just move it
to
[Music]
uh idea to come here
or
the problem is the the
if we're playing
yeah they covered so we're better right
i like that more than uh thinking about
b5 because b5 isn't forcing anything
we're making some threats but it's not a
forcing move
uh c sorry where
um oh b1
yeah
so check
king
b1 bishop revealed check with the row
okay
um
without the knight and bishop here the
king has the square uh yeah a lot of
people in the chat are suggesting some
ideas so
yeah so knight f3 is a good start
but it's going to force our king to move
and something useful here is we can see
what squares the king can go to
reveal checks or discover checks look
very nice here but actually this bishop
is doing a really nice job of cutting
off these two light squares
our knight is cutting off this dark
square
so the king actually can't move which
means that knight to f2
is just checkmate um kind of hard to see
but easier if we're looking at forced
moves
um
yeah another problem is yeah black's
work is pinned so if there are
discoveries that aren't also double
checks then white could take this rook
that's a really good point
all right let's move to the next one
here
so black to move and remember we're
going to start with forcing moves so
these are captures checks
um that kind of thing because that's
going to help us calculate
[Music]
okay
so this looks good right and then after
the king goes to the corner it's
checkmate but there's a bit of a problem
rookie one it's not forced right you
don't have to take
so they do get a move to do something
else
and probably
i don't know exactly what they might do
they can trade queens if they want to
um
but we're giving them time so this is a
move we can consider but i would want to
come back to this after we look at the
forcing moves
uh yeah if they move to the corner then
it's checkmate by force so we can
eliminate that variation
yes then our back rank here um because
the rook can't come back to block it is
now pinned by this bishop
yeah and a few people in chat saw that
as well so again that's the power of a
forcing move is we can see oh yeah
rookie one is threatening to undermine
this piece looks really valuable right
this looks great
but the problem is it's not actually
forced
white still has an option and in this
case
uh yeah just trading queens looks good
enough to stop the threats um
from here
like they can probably even just do this
and
it's
white's still gonna have an advantage
here so um
so starting with the forcing moves
again even in situations where they
don't work right there's a lot of times
where they don't and we'll actually get
to that later in this lesson
um but if you start them and you
eliminate them quickly then you can come
back and think okay what about some of
these non-forcing moves that still might
be good
all right next example here black to
move
there's a few different ideas i'm
curious to see what you all find
so again black to move and find
the best continuation
yeah few people are suggesting the right
move
but there's actually i think a few
forcing moves i want to talk about here
that we might not consider it one
um we can consider trading queens
we can consider taking this knight with
our bishop or our queen
and we can also consider our rook coming
down with check
if the rook comes down with check the
king has to take and then we win the
night
that looks nice
but we lost a rook
so we can eliminate that
queen takes
trading we can consider but i would come
back to trading if it's not getting us
an immediate advantage
i don't see this queen being off the
board and this bishop being
out does anything positive for us
but yeah bishop f2 does look very nice
and this is a
strictly forcing move right
white only has one response because the
rook is cutting off the king's escape
and it's defended by the queen so the
king can't take meaning queen has to
take
and after this a few you found the nice
idea of uh
undermining or deflecting i forget the
difference even though i taught a lesson
on it so go back and look at that lesson
if you want the
technical definition between those two
things but either way we are removing
the guard we're drawing the king away
from the queen
and we now take the queen
all right white to move
in our next position
what should we consider here
first we gotta identify the forcing
moves
yeah it looks like a few people in the
chat have some ideas the forcing moves
i'm noticing in this position are
um not really a lot of trades to happen
here we could trade bishops
and that would force the knight or the
rook to recapture
but again i don't see an immediate
advantage from that
we can take this pawn on f7 some people
in the chat have suggested that um and
there's also a queen sacrifice idea we
can do over here on h7 that calls check
all of these moves are forced
uh bishop takes f7 uh silencio 1982 i'm
curious what you would follow up with
after say king takes
i'm seeing maybe queen to f5
but unfortunately i think there's just
too many pieces right
a lot of black's pieces are able to come
to the aid of the king
i'm not sure bishop f7 is going to pan
out and a lot of other people in the
chat are finding this really nice idea
of queen to h7
and again we can calculate it without
even playing it right queen to h7 is a
forcing move where black has two options
they can take or they can run away
if they run away
then we can simply
bring the queen down to h8 with
checkmate
we don't have to calculate that
variation any farther
so instead they take
and after that what do we do
i think in the chat
yeah bishop takes f7 now
so queen here first
and bishop takes f7 cutting off the
escape
for the king and creating essentially a
back rank
really really nice
all right
uh it is black to move in this position
see what we can find
rook to d4
okay uh rook d4 and then
kane
goes
knight h3
yeah that looks
pretty checkmatey to me
um
what if it's after rook d4
g4 is played instead
yeah uh so in either case rook to d4 is
our starting variation and we always
want to think through all of the
possibilities so here white can either
move their king or move their pawn
if the pawn blocks then rook takes is
checkmate our knight is covering all the
escape squares the knight and rook
really coordinate well
and our pawn is covering the last escape
if king runs here instead
uh then yeah knight to h3 is a very
pretty checkmate alternatively you can
still play rook to g4 here this is also
checkmate but
again pick your poison so
all right
next example it is
white to move this one might be a little
more complex so take your time think it
through and think about the forcing
moves we got a lot of trades a lot of
checks
a lot of options white to move
so
so lots to think through here okay we
have some suggestions in the chat
so uh rook f7 is
i think probably the obvious suggestion
given the puzzles right we're looking at
forcing moves there are some checks
maybe some queen sacrifices to consider
but this seems to make the most sense
given what we've been looking at but we
have to think about everything
so if we take
this is i'd say a forcing move right
we're making a capture we're making some
threats
and it seems pretty obvious that black
would want to recapture so they can take
back with the knight or sorry with the
rook with the queen
or they don't have to recapture um
if they don't i think this attack is
going to be too overwhelming though
so let's start with maybe thinking if
rook takes right queen takes would be
the less obvious move and i generally
like to start a variation by thinking of
what is the best thing my opponent could
probably play here
um and then if that doesn't work then
i'll try the other ones just in case but
it's usually a good sign if their
strongest looking move doesn't actually
help them
so rook takes f7 and uh black recaptures
with the rook
unfortunately this undermines the knight
so yeah as uh
sam latib says yeah this knight we can
now take it with check
and now
there's a question if the rook moves
back
so work goes back to uh f8 here then our
rook and uh sorry our work on f1 and our
queen can take it
with checkmate we don't have to think
about that anymore
so we can instead think what if king to
e7
if king to e7 um
then queen f7 checkmate right our pawn
is cutting off this square
and our queen and again our rook on f1
do a beautiful job
so that looks pretty strong
what if uh something else takes what if
like the queen takes here on f7
what would we do then
how does white continue
after rook f7 queen f7
okay right you mean the other rook yeah
yep
all right other rook takes
and then there's a similar problem right
if this rook recaptures the night hangs
and they gave up a queen so we're just
doing much better materially and have a
great attack
and if not then our rook and queen
together are making huge threats so
that's good enough
and our last option right is if we take
with the rook and they don't want to
take the queen tries to run away the
problem is
there's nowhere the queen can go to stop
rook to f8 checkmate
so this is going to be our forcing move
i know we spent some extra time on that
but again i want to talk through the
benefits of it without actually playing
it out because in a game you don't get
to play it out and then do a take back
if it doesn't work we have to figure it
out in our heads right and this is the
benefit of
a forcing move so we can calculate these
variations ahead and eliminate them
easier this is the strongest looking
move but we can take this knight
if the rook goes back it's checkmate
so the king has to come up
but it's still checkmate
if the queen takes
then we take it with the rook and again
if the rook takes we hit the knight
and if not
then this is just a dominating force and
actually
yeah i don't see how you stop me from
taking the rook anyway so that's pretty
much forced
and there is nothing else you can't just
run away because this is checkmate
all right really good stuff next example
here
black to move
find the best move
or sequence of moves in this case
some of the tv we're finding these
pretty quick are you a secret master
let's see if anybody else can find the
specific variation
uh okay or rook g3 yeah
okay um
the only move right it is forced because
the bishop and queen cover the rest of
the squares so pawn takes back
i assume you're gonna take with the
queen
um and then
well looks like there's
two options you can either block with
the rook or run to the corner so
if they block with the rook
uh
yeah right it's just hanging
um
and if they move to the corner
um f3 again the rook
takes right yeah
so not quite there you're really close
to the right idea so
uh well yeah you let's see if you can do
in your head so rook takes here on g3
queen takes pawn takes king hides in the
corner
uh queen h4 being suggested then
uh that looks pretty interesting
threatening discoveries
although
maybe rook
h2
maybe not
so takes takes takes
king of the corner
queen if we're actually probably then we
can play like queen
d2
and wherever the bishop moves our rook
can come in and it's defended
yeah the key here is
recognizing that this rook is pinned
bishop to g2
and if the rook takes we get their queen
and if not
um
then
well if not then what
uh what's defending h2
okay
so here i would probably play
bishop f3 and
i've stopped them from hiding in the
corner
forcing them to either run to the side
or again block we know if they block its
checkmate
so hiding in the corner but this time
our bishop is covering all the key
squares so now our queen can kind of
finish off the job
all right
it is a white to move in this variation
see if you can find the right idea
kamachi that sounds like a pretty cool
stream
hope you had fun there
so white to move
what would you play
yeah so a few people in the chat are
suggesting an interesting move rook h4
and interestingly enough rook h4 is not
a forcing move at least by the
main way we've been interpreting it
right there is obviously checkmate
threats but
rook h4 is not a capture and it's not a
check
so some of the point for this one is
actually
rook h4 there's no way to stop checkmate
because we're threatening both
h7 and h8 so if
queen to f6
to defend h8 we go to h7
um
if something like rook to e8 to open up
space
then we go to h8 instead
but the tricky thing here is you know
we're thinking about forcing moves
so the first inclination is to think
what are the checks maybe there's some
queen sacrifices maybe there's some rook
sacrifices um but we can actually find
that none of them quite work uh rook
takes
uh queen takes and everything is going
to be defended
any queen sacrifice
the king will
kind of hide away on g7 and we don't
have enough
artillery to continue the attack so i
would still in these variations
recommend starting with those ideas and
saying okay i don't see a way to
continue with those we can quickly
eliminate them and move on
but you still did find the nice idea
which is maybe the next tier down of
forcing which is i'm not you know
taking a piece i'm not calling check but
i am making a serious threat
all right next example black to move
oh the new prince queen h5
oh sorry yeah just really quick to jump
back to this last one yeah rook h4 the
best move is technically queen h5 um and
it stops checkmate
um but we're going to get the queen
so yeah again what you don't always have
to calculate to checkmate if you get a
significant material advantage it's okay
to stop there because we know from
experience that a queen is going to be
able to beat a king in a rook and
actually probably in this variation i
might not even take this pawn i would
probably play here to take this one
um
and yeah white will easily win this game
but that's a good point
okay back to
our next example
[Music]
okay
so not a forcing move but you are making
a threat uh what's your threat
what's your what's your hope for this
position i suppose
yeah so with the nice idea that um the
rook is pinned so it wouldn't be able to
recapture slight issue they can just
take our queen
so remember anytime we're not playing a
forcing move we got to think of every
possibility
but it is a good thought
okay a few people are suggesting another
move that's not forcing queen to e3
um idea that okay we're still hitting
this rook uh it's still pinned we're
taking advantage of it
um
maybe
take on
e2 okay another option this is forcing
so let's do this first so bishop takes
rook
um
yeah because the bishop is covering
everything else and it's defended so
yeah bishop takes king takes
yeah queen to e3 um
king has to hide in the corner
yep checkmate so we found a checkmate
fully by force so we don't even need to
think about queen e3 right queen e3
looks really really interesting it's a
move i would love to spend some time
calculating but i only want to do that
if there's not something easier right
because in fact queenie 3 i believe uh
loses to
c4
stopping the pin from working
um and everything is just magically
defended
for for white um so they're actually
surviving this and going to be ahead
because they're going to get one of our
pieces
maybe even two
so really nice idea but
that's one of the benefits to starting
with the forcing moves is it either
works or it doesn't
and then you can spend some more time on
some serious ideas like like this
all right
next position here
light to move
oh
uh and we'll jump back real quick so
yeah you're saying we can take the pawn
um so i think there is a slight problem
with that
after c4
is yeah knight takes
and then um
i guess we can take the bishop here
and then they'll take ours and it's
going to be kind of complicated but
like the way it all runs out is you know
queen for a queen
rook for a rook and white's just flat
out three pieces
so even if we get one of those we're
still going to be down way too much
okay
back to our next example
you know great question new prince it's
good to like think about things that i
might have overlooked um
there's lots of complexities to all
these positions
take on
c2
yeah yeah so a few suggestions here
queen a4 was suggested which again looks
maybe interesting but probably runs into
like b5 ideas or bishop d2 ideas we can
trade queens and maybe stop them from
castling which is a nice strategic
advantage or we can just do a knockout
blow
bishop f2 and their queen is dead
long live the queen next example
black to move
and find the best idea
and yeah good job finding that as well
not wise man 1986
okay action sandwich i love your name uh
wanting to play sacrifice queen takes c1
i like it
i like it uh
the response is forced
either they take with the bishop or the
queen blocks if the queen blocks it is
checkmate
so bishop takes and checkmate anyway
quite quite lovely
black to move and win
maybe not by checkmate maybe by
checkmate you'll have to figure that out
yourself but it is going to be a nice
advantage one way or another
what should black play here
my
uh
black to move
is is a little trickier
but again if we start with our forcing
moves so checks and captures especially
okay chess blunts nice
uh
check
well there's actually only one check in
this position
so rook to c2 i presume
um
king's gonna move somewhere it's got a
bunch of moves but we do notice that the
king is tied to this bishop so that
eliminates at least these two squares
but that still leaves four squares open
however you make a really good point
after check we can do another forcing
move
it doesn't matter where this king goes
because our next move will be to take
the bishop
sacrificing the rook for it so this is
an exchange sacrifice but this is a
forcing move because the king is forced
to recapture if they don't
then black just has a free bishop
so recaptures and then the really nice
uh fork
bishop to b6
and again that's the the power of
forcing moves i really just want to
emphasize how much this can
revolutionize your game if you're not
using this already uh noticing that okay
we have a check in this position
and wherever the king moves so again
we're eliminating as many variations as
we can
we either win the bishop if the king
moves away
we just straight up win it or if the
king stays in range we take it
and force all of these variations
to submerge into one with the king on f2
and we can
win back the rook so we win the bishop
anyway
really really good stuff
okay
white to move
what should white play here
there's a few different forcing moves
but only one of them is good enough to
work
uh rook d8 okay check
um
black only has two moves right you can't
move the king so you gotta block with
the knight either on e8 or on g8
e8 looks a little silly because we'll
just take it and win so
g8 and
you can then
take with your rock okay so take the
knight another forcing move check king
has to take
and then
queen
yeah
and we're cutting off the escape square
so this one's really important because
some people might say oh what if i
played like the queen first draw the
knight away
and then i bring my rook down and
there's no way to save the night
unfortunately it's not a back rank one
because the king it's not a forcing move
they have one move that they can push
upon to try and escape
um actually even worse than that though
is because it's not a forcing move they
also have their own time to make their
threats so they can get checkmate on us
um so it's good to calculate these
things out
uh guarantee answered this i don't know
if you were the one who posted or
someone else never heard of that
particular gambit
all right another complicated position
here for you
white to move
what should we do here a lot of forcing
moves to consider
there's checks there's captures there's
sacrifices
how should white
come out ahead in this game
okay i have suggestion of queen takes
pawn
uh we can't take back with a rook so
queen takes
then what do you want to do uh
cj0467
yeah where's the mate
yeah so the rook can't take its pin but
there is a queen hiding back here so not
quite checkmate there
and even if the rook takes
king takes we can take the rook
but in the end we'll have lost all three
of our pieces
and only gotten
two a rook a queen and a pawn and black
still has our work in a bishop so taking
the pawn is not good enough
uh rook
is on g3
okay so not a forcing move uh what's the
idea there
well i don't think there's any way you
can get checkmated before
interesting point so you're threatening
like checkmating ideas with the queen
over here and
yeah yeah so this is actually the right
idea but i want to emphasize
the power of doing the forcing moves
first right we can quickly eliminate
yeah queen takes g7 doesn't work there's
ideas of bishop takes on f7 check um
unfortunately
you know the queen's gonna take and
now our queen's under fire there's no
time but in this position everything is
trapped right this queen is stuck
defending these pieces the rook is
pinned uh and our bishop is actually
keeping this work out of the game
so rook h3
is a quiet move this is not a forcing
move but we can eliminate all of our
forcing options see that none of them
work and recognize that yeah black just
doesn't have a choice here um
bishop h4 yeah it does prolong it
i guess we take um
maybe there's some ideas of like moving
the queen away
but yeah this is gonna be tough so let's
see
what uh the best way black can put up
some resistance here
so yeah i think anything other than
bishop h4
like if you try to move the queen out of
the way what happens
yeah maintenance ii right check and
checkmate
so you have to block with the bishop
this actually does change things
um because now
after we take and the queen moves
there is an escape square
so what do we do here
uh
do you mean just take the rook yeah
okay queen takes
okay king f8
i'm scared yeah king still manages to
get away unfortunately there's not quite
a way to get a checkman in this position
but we can get some nice material
advantage so think through forcing moves
and see if you can find a way to get a
material edge
because right now we're still down a
rook for a bishop essentially a bishop
and a pawn for a rook so it's close but
um and obviously we're going to trade
this bishop at some point
but how can we actually get
so you're you're close um you just gotta
switch the order a little bit
okay take the brook first yes
yes
yeah and this is forcing because if the
queen doesn't take
then we're just taking their queen
so queen has to take and now
yeah really beautiful again a deflection
here and we get the queen queen for a
rook should be
relatively easy win for
white
all right we've got a few minutes left
here
and you know what
let's go through i'll skip ahead here i
have a few more examples but i want to
show you a really pretty game
um
with the last five minutes we have this
is called the boston immortal
and there's a really cool forcing
sequence that i want to share with you
but uh
i think the immortal games if you've
ever heard of them it's a series of
chess games that you know people just
have command commemorated with these
titles
um
and they're
very very pretty
this game happened in the 1800s 1892
in boston that's where it gets the name
and it starts out with a danish gambit
d4
uh pawn to c3 and d takes white
gambiting these two pawns for some rapid
development
bishop to c4 actually enticing black to
continue grabbing pawns uh however this
is a bit scary
with uh white having these beautifully
developed bishops
um
active and ready to go on the hunt for
the king so black decided to be a little
more calm and just you know develop
another piece knight to f6
knight to f3
knight takes e4
taking another pawn
white castles so fully developed and
this cuts this has kind of a scotch
gambit feel and the danish and the
scotch can kind of
transpose in some ways
but after castles
black played the move knight to d6 not
the best move
um
threatening the bishop here
uh and bishop to b3 is actually a very
strong move for white in this case white
uh went a little crazy and gambited some
more knight takes c3 allowing knight to
take c4 with the idea that there is a
lot of pressure on this open king
rook to e1 check
forcing bishop to e7 obviously you don't
want to give up the queen and bringing
the knight back doesn't actually change
anything so bishop to e7
putting more pressure on our pinned
piece here knight to d5
uh knight to c6 to defend
and bishop out to g5 attacking again
hoping to
you know possibly win the queen or just
get a really strong attack here white
did end up sacrificing a bishop
and uh black plays f6 a bit of a
desperation move but this is actually
the best
and with you know a computer engine
defending black is actually doing okay
here but it is very scary practically
uh white plays a move rook to c1
with the idea that if you now take my
bishop i will take your knights and
double up my rooks and this is going to
be really really painful
so instead black plays the move b5
defending the knights not taking their
bishop and white plays kind of a crazy
move here rook takes c4 sacrificing the
rook anyway
um with the idea that they're kind of
eliminating this defender
pawn takes
and now
knight to e5 another just insane move
um with kind of a fun idea in the game
pawn takes the bishop but
if uh something had taken here on e5
let's say knight takes e5
then rook takes sacking again
f takes
and the queen is trapped
funny enough
this is actually maybe not the worst
thing for black
because white has sacrificed so much
material that
this position is going to be kind of
wacky
but um again this this was an old game
so he didn't want to lose his queen
so it takes g5
and this is a blunder
queen to h5 and this is where our
forcing sequence begins
white has sacrificed a bunch of material
and now can find a really forcing attack
queen h5
and unfortunately there's only one move
right if king to f8
this is checkmate so
g6 is forced
and here another a really beautiful
forcing move another check is knight to
f6 now knight to g6 normally would be a
very strong move and that is going to
come soon with the idea that we're going
to pick up the rook
but that's not quite enough for white
here they have sacrificed a lot they
need more than just some material
returned
so knight to f6 check
in the game we have bishop to bishop
takes because again
if king f8 then we have checkmate with
queen to h6
everything is covered
so bishop takes the knight is forced
and now knight takes g6 to check
black has a lot of options but this is
still a forcing move but you can block
with a lot
so what did black play in the game
surprisingly black actually plays queen
to e7
but let's look at some of their other
options very quickly if a move like
bishop to e7
then
white could probably continue something
like knight to e5
and then king to f8 is forced and this
is checkmate
if uh king had gone to f7 to try and
prevent some of that
then maybe again knight to e5 this is
double check the king has to move
and there's going to be a problem no
matter where you move
if you go over to g7
then you are going to get mated on the
edge of the board
very painfully
if instead uh you go to anywhere uh well
let's say you go to the back either to
f8 or to g8 same thing
checkmate on f7 as before
and if you go anywhere on the e-file
then i am winning your queen
and
pretty soon i will be winning the game
so for all of those reasons queen to e7
is played in the game
another forcing move rook takes e7 check
uh forcing the bishop to take
knight to e5 check
king still can't go to f8 because again
there is checkmate in one
so king goes to d8
and i will turn it over to
the audience it is white to move
and play the best sequence in this
position
white has given up nearly all of their
pieces
but they've done it seeing all of this
ahead
yeah some people are starting to think
about it
got some good ideas
yeah new prince we can fork the king and
the rook but that's not quite gonna be
good enough because even if we get the
rook we'll have a queen and knight
versus uh a rook knight and bishop pear
uh you know maybe white has a slight
edge there but it's it's too close for
me to want to play it out comfortably
yeah it's going to be kind of weird and
close
but yeah but uh chess blunts and my name
is buffalo you both found the right idea
this is a pattern that we've looked at
before uh the smothered mate
knight f7 is how we start but we're not
looking at the rook we're looking at the
king
because once the king moves we have a
double check knight to d6
you cannot take
again if you go to f8 this is mate
so you have to go back to d8
and from here there's checkmate in two
moves
all forced
first
queen to e8
why can't you do that you've done that
right away
uh so you can't because the difference
is
the knight's not defending um the knight
can still get here but i can't do it now
if rook takes this is still a smothered
mate
but the rig doesn't have to take yeah
you need the knight to be defending this
square for it to work so we have to kind
of reroute a little bit
and then we can pull it off king can no
longer take and
checkmate it's a really really beautiful
game um
hope that you enjoyed that but more
importantly i hope that you took to
heart some of the ideas about forcing
moves um now obviously we were looking
at puzzles i did throw in some where
forcing moves weren't the answer and you
have to think a little more creatively
but
the point is it's extremely beneficial
to your chess game because even if the
forcing move doesn't work
it's one more eliminated sequence you
don't have to think about it and if it
does work
then play it you've got there
so hopefully this will help you with
your calculation save you some time
mental effort
and help you win the battle of attrition
against your opponent and also maybe
spot some moves you wouldn't have
considered otherwise some sacrifices
that can lead to really pretty
endings to some games
so i hope you've enjoyed this stream my
name is alex mullering again thank you
for coming to beginner breakdown and
hope to see you again soon